wheat from ukraine arrives in africa the
first aid shipment from the world food
program reached harbour in late august
carrying much-needed grain destined for
ethiopia since july only two such
humanitarian deliveries have taken place
while more than a hundred commercial
cargo ships have set sail from ukraine
russia says european countries are the
biggest winners
practically all the grain exported from
ukraine has been shipped not to the
developing and poorest countries but to
the countries of the european union
just as many european countries acted in
previous centuries as colonialists
this is how they continue acting today
they have once again cheated the
developing countries and continue
cheating them
under the black sea grain initiative
ships from ukraine passed through an
inspection center in turkey
the majority of their cargo stays in
turkey which buys some 19
of the rest european union countries
have collectively bought 38
followed by asia and the middle east
african countries have so far received
just six percent of all the exports
while the poorest nations have seen the
least of ukraine's grain the united
nations has defended the deal saying it
has helped by putting downward pressure
on global food prices
because of that drop people who had been
hoarding grain and hoping to sell it at
a high price are actually now selling it
which is putting more
on the market and hopefully that
will bring some of those local prices
down too
russia is also upset that its fertilizer
exports haven't restarted as agreed
under the deal
a pipeline carrying the fertilizer
ingredient ammonia from russia to
ukraine's odessa for export by sea has
been closed since the start of the war
the u.n is trying to get it flowing
again
time is running out the current deal
expires in november unless all sides
agree grain and fertilizer exports from
ukraine could again come to a halt
let's get more from yulia han in
istanbul welcome julia is president
erdogan likely to be sympathetic to
president putin's
dissatisfaction with this grain deal
well the turkish president played a key
role in brokering this so-called grain
deal back in july he has i believe no
interest in seeing it fail turkey is one
of the countries that has so far
received most of the grain shipments
from ukraine but erdogan is also
carefully balancing interests between
kiev and moscow and he has uh echoed
putin's criticism of the deal but i
should add that putin's claims and i
quote him here that almost all of the
grain shipments have so far gone to
european union countries is simply not
correct not according to the figures we
have
from the united nations who are
overseeing the entire process they say
that about a third of all exports have
so far gone to low and lower
middle-income countries in asia the
middle east and africa so the question
is why is putin trying to discredit this
deal now i believe it is because russia
thinks it's not benefiting from the
agreement the agreement officially also
allows russia to export grain and
fertilizer free of sanctions but that's
not uh it seems that's not what is
happening right now in practice uh
russian grain exports have decreased in
recent months the numbers of countries
buying or willing to buy from russia has
decreased there are still many
restrictions when it comes to shipping
companies uh to insurance to banking now
turkish officials say they have pushed
on an international level for that to
change so i think this is going to be at
the core of what president erdogan and
president putin are going to talk about
today when it comes to that grain deal
and you you mentioned uh
mr erdogan's balancing act with russia
as a member of nato a russian military
client and and with competing interests
in syria he's it's going to be hard for
him not to be accused of of playing both
sides
well this is already uh president
edwan's third face-to-face meeting with
vladimir putin since russia invaded
ukraine in february i should add that
turkey is not a member of this shanghai
corporation organization but erdogan was
invited by vladimir putin to attend now
this summit
led by russia and china is seen by some
as an anti-western alliance so i believe
uh erdogan's attendance is eyed with a
lot of skepticism by turkey's
partners in the west in europe in the
u.s
ankara has so far
not joined any western sanctions on
moscow
western capitals are unhappy with that
russia turkey continues to receive
tourists and finances from russia
they're continuing to trade and there
are serious concerns on western capitals
that turkey might be helping russia to
avoid sanctions so i think uh this
summit today also uh sends a signal to
the west
thank you for that uh yulia julia han in
istanbul